[Music]
welcome to earbiscuits the podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm link and I'm Rhett this
week at the round table of demm lighting
we're going to be finding out just how
good or bad of a rider we each are a
rider a rider you're not talking about a
horse rider rider a passenger you're
talking about a in an Uber an Uber Rider
M okay there's there there's now a way
to find out maybe there's always been a
way and no one explained it to me okay
all right and I know that you're also
like really big into a new thing that
like you just you're so excited about
talking about the funny thing about it
is is like it's become so much of a
bigger thing because we've almost
included it in the past like three
episodes and it actually com for time it
isn't yeah it's the thing that keeps
getting cut for time and now it's kind
of built up and I I I F you know what
I'm not going to disappoint you I'm not
going to disappoint you I'm potentially
going to change your
life well I have something to add uh
this week so you might get it cut for
time no I'm going first you go first
okay what uh well link last episode you
asked me to make you a vision board
based off of your passions and I made
you a vision board really yes well I
feel like I should have ranked my
passions yeah he should have I would
have made you one too oh okay all right
did you go a little rogue don't don't
well don't tell me you'll have to see
all right I'll have to see it oh I got a
vision board I have it hidden it's
hidden under my desk big yeah I have it
hidden under my desk little is it
framable it is anything's framable
speaking of framable um one of the best
Christmas gifts I got I still have not
put up on my wall and it was
framed uh Lily surprised me with a she
emulated like a like a concert poster
like a venue poster but it was
um Lincoln Lily's listening party Spa
listening party or something hot tub hot
tub it's not in front of me so I can't
remember exactly hot tub listening party
and it was like it was an event cuz we
would get in the hot tub and listen to
music and like I would turn
on she just had a friend who was a
graphic designer who like made made it
isn't that sweet oh that's so sweet it's
so sweet and it's so sweet that I have
never done anything that sweet for me I
haven't put it up haven't put it up how
big are we talking um you know it's like
a 11 by 17 you know it's like a well
that made you feel special made me feel
special and now I got to follow through
I got to put that thing up in my I think
I'm going put it in my office in the
creative house you know it's like I can
put anything I want on my walls in my
office it's a great reason to have a
creative house I don't have to have like
Buy in from you know can't put it in
your bedroom family or chrisy Christy
runs point on like the aesthetic of
everything in the house and this doesn't
quite fit you know that's why my realm
is the garage but I don't have any art
hanging on the wall in the garage
there's no room for
that yeah there's like equipment
cabinets and Equipment toys yeah um
trash you know that reminds me something
that I talked about with Jesse recently
that I failed to talk about on the
podcast and I and this is something that
I built up years ago and you know about
it yeah that's right I know what you're
talking about because I when you talk
about something framed in the creative
house the best gift you've ever gotten I
I built up that Jesse had got me the
best gift that I've ever gotten and I
recently had a discussion with her and
with some friends who were looking at it
and I came to the conclusion that I did
want to talk about it but but I do not
want to show
it three years later it it's two years
later really yeah and I want to make
sure I mean I think it's been three
years I don't know just want to make
sure I'm
getting um what are you doing what are
you
googling oh I'm just making sure that
I'm get that I'm getting his uh
information
right
okay um
so what it was was
Jesse has a has a friend who used to run
uh or be associated with an art gallery
and there was an artist this pen and ink
artist named Ronnie Ray I think Ronnie
Ray Mendes um who is just a great like
pen and ink you know artist and he had I
don't think he had done this particular
thing before but Jesse was talking to a
friend and she was like Rhett really
likes pen and Inc and I've got this idea
where I want to like give a pen and ink
artist like information about him and us
you know as a
couple and like can I like write like a
story about him like his life and then
have somebody create like a pen and ink
drawing that is representative of
Rett and when I say pen and ink you know
how detailed it is but when I say pen an
ink that's literally like 4 feet by 3
feet I mean the thing's this big yeah
it's huge it's the it's the width of the
couch in your office me the way she the
way she got me with this
is she was like it's going to be your
birthday present then it was like it's
going to be your Christmas present it
kept getting pushed back because it it
was it was so detailed it was so
detailed and I don't know if he had done
one this big before and he's like so
talented and so committed to like
making it amazing that he just was like
I'm going to work on this until it's
done and she was like it's fine so was
an autobiographical piece of
art and I don't want to descri the
reason I don't want to talk about the
specific well let me tell you the story
of how she revealed it to me she was
like I'm going to give you this present
but we have to drive to this place in
the
valley and like we kind of drove to like
some
like a weird part of the like western
side of the the valley okay and I was
like what in the hell is this going to
be and then all of a sudden like we we
pull up next to this car and there's a
dude in the car you were like in a
Walmart parking lot or something it was
like a parking lot in a strip mall oh
and but kind of in a weird like weird
weird strip mall that didn't had weird
stores and we get out and she's like
it's in the back of this guy's SUV and
I'm like is it a dog like I you know
when somebody has got you the best gift
they've ever gotten you and they're
taking you into a parking lot yeah and
then you're just opening in the back of
back of this guy's car it's probably
illegal and he's an interesting looking
guy you know I was like what does this
guy have in his truck and then she opens
it up and there's a sheet over something
and then he like takes the sheet off and
like I had no idea so all of a sudden I
look at this thing and I'm like holy
[__] this is like this am this amazing
drawing yeah uh but then she was like
well look closely at it then I started
looking at it I was like oh [__] this is
custom and this is this is for me and
then she's like then he hands me this or
no she I can't remember who had it this
like manila envelope that had the story
in it which is like this is the
information that she gave him to then
have him create this artistic
representation of my life and like our
life
together and so it's just it's so
personal that I kind of want it to be
something that's just like you can come
into the creative house and see it you
can if you're my friend but I don't want
to like show it to the internet but I
wanted I just felt bad because this guy
Ronnie Ray worked so Ronnie Ray Mendes
worked so hard on it that you know I
mean I paid him for it of course but
like I want he's so good at what he does
and he does this isn't the only thing he
does he does other stuff too but um he
worked on it for over a year right no it
wasn't a year but it was months it's not
it's not his full-time job he has
another job I can't remember what it is
but so this is like a nights and
weekends kind of thing and you can only
spend so much time it's super just
sitting there and get like when you look
closely you you can stand there I've had
friends stand there for 30 minutes
looking at it and then I'll be like well
this means this and this means this and
this I don't even really know maybe
Jesse knows like when I was looking at
it with Jesse a couple weeks ago with
with uh some friends yeah she was
pointing out things that I was like oh I
didn't realize that what that was
for she remembers because she gave him
all the promps it's kind of like a it's
a
Fantastical representation of your life
that does require like like kind of
telling a story in your mind you're like
making
connections between your life and this
it's not so it's uh it's pretty it's
it's like it's very cool and like the
style is very intricate but it also kind
of shifts there's like some very
photorealistic parts and then there's
like some super Fantastical parts and it
kind of all mixes together yeah it's
like a giant landscape kind of when
we've been brainstorming like the last
time we were
brainstorming we were in your office and
I just found myself kind of staring at
it because it can kind of send your mind
in a bunch of different ways yeah you
know it's like oh there's the nature
part and then there's like there's like
a car you used to drive in it it wasn't
even a car that I drove it was a car I
wanted that's right yeah okay I'm not
going to give any any more details away
but it it definitely blew me away that's
probably I mean that's an heirloom
that's like that's that's a hell of a
gift it is the best gift I've ever
gotten and of course I haven't seen the
vision board that Jenna made but I
that's not a gift because I commissioned
it as a as you did it in working hours
well yeah maybe you didn't okay all
right I'll take it as a gift you might
take some a lot to do you got a lot to
do so had a lot to do in other words I
need to love it cuz it's it's part of
this as a gift you don't you don't need
to love it I need to love it I really we
can't tell you that you want me to do
something and then me not go and do it
even if you're joking or not that's true
I'm excited okay before we talk about
before we dig into our Uber Uber ratings
so we get to see our Uber ratings oh God
okay yeah okay let's this is pretty
exciting this is a long time coming uh
in celebration of the 5-year anniversary
of the mythical Society of course that
is our exclusive uh fan club where you
can pay at different levels to receive
things that are worth what you're paying
for there's also an initiate level that
is is start raving free and you can just
check out everything we have over there
five years of accumulated exclusive
content uh growing every week we have
now gamified the mythical Society app
right so there's the app where you can
enjoy everything from the society but
now uh you can play along every day with
Good Mythical Morning uh even as an an
initiate all you you can have the free
initiate level now what does that mean
to play along sometimes we play games
and you can't play along because you get
a different um experience comedically by
knowing the answers so we're not talking
about that as much as um there's there's
some ways that like our competition can
relate to your competition but then
there's this other forms of knowledge
you'll have to play it to see it's like
a it's it's trivia B it's trivia based
called think it and sink it get get
it can accumulate a score we we almost
called it think make me horny but yeah
we we didn't call it that but was was a
close second you so you want to play
over the course of the season and then
we're going to be recognizing uh
there'll be special prizes at the end of
this next season a good mythical morning
for those who have accumulated wi uh
right answers so that's pretty cool
pretty excited about that uh we give out
um exclusive quarterly collectible items
like physical collectible items every
quarter over the past 5 years and
they're only available to third degree
members who are members at the time um
with some stipulations always valuable
super collectible and then they're gone
but if there's some that in the past you
wish you could have gotten now is the
time to get those while supplies last um
we have like a little additional
inventory of some of these things like
whether it's in one of the exclusive
albums we released or um the comic book
series that we're we we released
three um additions of that you know and
if you want to get all those or if you
want like the blanket or the uh the
hoodie blanket thing like all the super
cozy stuff we release exclusively like
um any new purchase upgrade renewal or
gift any way that you can get a third
degree annual
plan through January 20 uh I said
January I meant February
through February
29th uh if you sign up for any thir I'm
not doing a good job of saying this
that's why we wrote it down and I should
just read it if you get a third deegree
annual plan in any form including a gift
card through February
29th uh you will have the choice of any
of the past quarterly items we've ever
produced while supplies last first come
first served so go to mythical
society.com for all that
stuff ear biscuits is supported by chime
you know I I pretty much put all my
purchases on my credit card you know I I
plan to pay it off in full every month
but like I I run it through that to
build my credit you know what I'm saying
I know what you're saying you're talking
about building credit link I'm talking
about building credit right no matter
how you're starting off the year when
you use the secured chime credit Builder
Visa credit card you can build your
credit scores with on Time payments for
everyday purchases if there were an
overachieving credit card that helps you
build credit this would be it when your
credit's good your future is also good
there are no annual fees interest or
credit check to apply and you can use it
everywhere Visa credit cards are
accepted by the way you get a checking
account too to set up a qualifying
direct deposit sign up for spot me and
chime will spot you up to your limit
when you make a credit card purchase or
cash withdrawal that exceeds your
balance plus you have access to over
60,000 fee free ATMs easily found on the
chime app that's more than the top three
National Banks combined so start
building your credit open a chime
checking account with at least a $200
qualifying direct deposit to get started
get started at chime.com that's
chime.com the chime credit Builder Visa
credit card is issued by the bank cor
Bank NA or stride Bank NA members FDIC
out of network ATM withdrawal and
over-the-counter Advance fees May apply
call
8442446363 for details late payment May
negatively impact your credit score
results May Vary Early Access to direct
deposit funds depends on payer spot me
eligibility requirements and overdraft
limit Supply ear bits is is supported by
Rosetta Stone you know sometimes you
travel to other countries link like you
just traveled to New Zealand and
sometimes um you need to help
understanding the people in that country
well a lot of them speak English oh okay
well maybe this doesn't apply as much
but berther accent is so strong that it
sounds like another language in comes
Rosetta Stone not exactly it's not for
accents I mean it's for accents within
languages just let me stick with the
copy Rosetta Stone is the most trusted
language learning program available on
desktop or as an app that truly immerses
you in the language you want to learn
they've used trusted experts for 30
years with millions of users and 25
languages offered some of which include
Spanish French German Korean Chinese
Japanese Dutch and Arabic I don't see
New Zealand is on there no but probably
because that's English uh or mayori
Rosetta Stone immerses you in many ways
there are no English translations so you
really learn to speak listen and think
in that language and with their built-in
true accent feature that gives you
feedback on your pronunciation you'll be
speaking like a pro in no time plus it's
an amazing value a lifetime membership
has all 25 languages for any and all
trips or language needs in life a
$399 program but with our code you can
get it for just $19 $9 don't put off
learning that language there's no better
time than right now to get started for a
very limited time you can get Rosetta
Stone's lifetime membership for 50% off
that's 50% off for unlimited access to
25 language courses for the rest of your
life redeem your 50% off at
rosettastone.com
today okay link uh it's a lot of fun
over there so Jamie found this uh Tik
Tok was going around and basically it's
uh this woman who is saying I I don't
know if it's always been there or if
they just recently I don't know either
this available but I know for the
longest time you couldn't see I thought
the impression was you couldn't see your
rating like you knew your driver's
rating but you didn't know your rating
and I always wondered like because
drivers can rate you oh you they do rate
you every time oh um and I was kind of
thinking oh they don't rate me so I'm
going to show you how to get to the
ratings and I will show you as as you
are listening or watching so you can
look at your your ratings too if you use
Uber and uh I'm interested to see I I
had some things that I was a little bit
worried about yeah I'm worried about
something so I'm interested how our
ratings
compare okay yeah and then why well you
know I just recently went on an Uber
against my will no it's my fault why
don't you tell them re what you
did so link and I typically do not
carpool unless we're recording an
episode of car biscuits for the mythical
Society right um
but we live relatively close to each
other and we work very close to each
other so sometimes it does make sense
yeah you you uh texted me as I was about
to leave one morning and you said hey
can you give me a ride I like sure bud I
didn't call you bud I've never never
called you bud seriously but you know
something like that I'd like for you to
do that and I picked you up and I
brought you in and of course the
understanding was I felt so seen
understanding was that I would also take
you
home but yeah uh I didn't want to I
forgot about it I didn't feel like I I
need to establish that but it's like
yeah I actually said in the
text what are you doing at the end of
the day can you give me a ride in and
and bring me back home you did ask for
you covered both I did say that cuz I
didn't want to ask for a ride in and
then be stranded listen I I have no
defense here it's just 100% my fault I
came in here to record uh an episode of
dispatches from Myrtle Beach with my dad
and boy we got on a roll yep you know
when I start talking to my dad boy we
get on a roll sometimes uhhuh and uh I
was you know had that wonderful time
with him and I step out of the booth and
I go right into our office right here
right behind us so close sh wall it's
the type of thing that if you decideed
you know what I'm going to leave I'm
going I'm just going to leave work you
might be reminded cuz the next door you
see is the one that the friend that you
brought to work is behind yeah yeah
still working I knew you were still in
there I just forgot I brought you to
work I open and going out into the
parking lot and not seeing your car did
not no Bells went
off uhuh it didn't did it well the big
bell went off when I went into the pitch
black office of ours like it's not a
light on there's not a soul there's not
a trace come on I didn't turn the lights
off there's not a trace I didn't shut
down of humanity
I'm not a light Turner offerer that's
you man I I mean I should I should be
more responsible it was desolate in
there and it's just my heart just sunk
and I'm like oh my God I'm stranded what
am I going to do and interestingly this
is actually kind of a I feel like this
is more of an offense for me to do it to
you than for you to do it to me because
you really hate Ubers you really hate
you hate having people take you anywhere
you don't even like just to be honest
with you like anytime we have to go to
to the West Side like if I don't say
anything I know you're going to be like
I'll drive and like I'm always like he's
got some reason that he wants to drive
it's probably I I'm not I'm not even
going to ask but I don't mind not
driving but it's a win-win so I'm like
you don't like to be driven anywhere
okay you're bringing up a couple of
things here um you're highlighting why
I'm so nervous about the fact that now
I'm about to see my Uber reviews I'm a
little nervous because I thought I just
had IM immunity and I also knew that I
was always upset when I'm in an Uber and
I got to tell you what happened with the
Uber that you stuck me in too but before
I get to that I just as a side note want
to say okay that yeah whenever we have
to drive to the West Side I like to be
the one to drive
because
um I like
driving you know I enjoy it I like
getting places fast I thought it was
because you were less you were more
likely to get sick if you were riding
I'm also more likely to get sick ESP go
over the hills and stuff especially when
if I'm in the passenger seat I can't be
on my phone and like if we get in a
conversation about something it usually
requires some form of like phone work
like and then people are communicating
with us it's during a work day there's
like work is happening and we're being
slacked and stuff and I'll get sick if
I'm on my phone so I can serve the duo
better by being the driver and then you
can be on your phone and you can
actually do things you also like to type
I don't like to type I like to drive I
don't like to type and I can't do it in
a car anyway so this is a win-win I'm
not complaining about it yep cuz my
driving is not bad I mean Stevie is
scared of me driving for some reason I
know it's cuz I've almost hit pass
pedestrians I'm a little bit scared of
how you but like we get there um and I
think I get I get there pretty fast you
haven't actually hit any pedestrians you
only almost hit pedestrians there's a
big difference like there's a like you
know if you actually hit somebody we got
a problem if you at somebody it's sort
of like it's almost like you didn't hit
them at all exactly in fact it's the
same missing a pedestrian is not ever
hitting a pedestrian right it's like
they weren't even there right so I've
I've missed a lot of pedestrians all of
them almost counts in horseshoes and
hitting pedestrians I don't know I'm
trying to almost doesn't count in
horseshoes but it does count in hitting
pedestrians almost almost almost almost
only counts in Hors shoes and Hand
Grenades it does it does count with
pedestrians and it does count with
pedestrians no it doesn't if you if you
nearly miss a pedestrian you have not
hit The Pedestrian so it doesn't count
just one little thing first of all I
already did apologize to you in real
life sorry for leaving you um I feel
like I deserved it I will say from the
Emmy thing uh I will say it was the day
of the uh NCAA football championship
game which starts at 4 freaking 30 on
the west coast and so once the end of
the day started rolling around I was
like and and lock was still in town I
was like oh I've got to watch this game
with my son and so I left work early and
I mean you conveniently forgot about
remembering your friend or watching
football with your son I'm sorry I got
to get my priorities straight I gave you
a hard time over text I was like it's
not a big deal I mean I could have
gotten a ride with somebody here but I
you know I had already asked Jenna to
make a vision board I didn't want to ask
her to take me
home I did offer I was like do you need
a ride I was like I'll just Uber it's
fine that's what Uber's for and um I was
like well I'm going to get the Comfort
it's a little few more dollars but I
want to be comfortable a little few more
and I get in the back of this um
Uber and homeboy been smoking cigarettes
V diagram Uber driver and smoker they
just don't more more likely you know
usual it
wasn't it I get I get just like an
immediate headache with some with with
some cigarette smoke like I'm just like
it's it's the worst for me it's so it's
it triggers a headache 110% of the time
and he you know just because you get out
of your car and you smoke your cigarette
doesn't mean that when you get back in
your car I can't smell it there's
something about it's on you it's on your
person it's still coming out of your
person somehow man and so here I am like
rolling the window down okay I rolled
the window and I felt bad about rolling
the window down day was that it was it
was prettyy chilly okay all right you're
rating I'm rolling the window down and I
feel like I'm sending him a message that
I I'd rather not be like hey something
around here stinks and I think it's you
some rolling the window down I didn't
like that but what was the look on your
face and did he have sunglasses on and
could you see him looking in the
rearview mirror I wasn't looking at him
I was kind of looking down I rolled the
window down I kind of stuck my nose out
I needed to I needed to like golden
retriever you headed out a little bit
the funny thing is I did it the place
where I did it is right before we get on
the interstate here in Burbank and when
I rolled the window down oh no you oh no
you did it during next to the plant with
the natural gas that comes out of yeah
it's there is a place in I call a fart
bridge when you cross the bridge a fart
Bridge you cross the bridge that goes
over the five on Burbank Boulevard it's
a fart bridge in Burbank stinks you will
if you haven't crossed it before every
single time you will assume that someone
maybe you farted and that's what my Uber
driver thought I did cuz I rolled the
window down so it's like I roll the
window down he smells a stink oh it's
like this dude farted in the back of my
car oh [__] and so like here I am
thinking about how bad he stinks he's
thinking about how bad I stink but you
did at least roll in the window down and
then I'm driving and we get you're
driving oh this gets
interesting I'm I'm riding and we get he
doesn't know how to drive in the traffic
and I'm like man if I was driving I'd be
way over here I'd be cutting people off
is taking twice as long to get home and
I'm getting and I'm smelling this stuff
he didn't carpol Lane he didn't carpool
lane and he's not aggressive and I mean
it was good that he wasn't talking to me
I did like that there were no words
exchanged except just the insinuation of
what the window rolling down meant by
the time we get close to the house I
look up and here we are going the wrong
direction he has taken a wrong turn and
at this point I
decide I'm going to I'm going to let him
have in the review I've I've never done
this but here I am angry and my head
hurts and it's really I'm mad at Rett
and I need to take it out on somebody
and I get home and I tell Christy about
it I'm like I'm thinking about writing
reviews she was like well that's what
it's for write it and the way that they
once you start writing like I put two
stars no I put one star o and then I was
like you know what I feel this isn't
that bad I'm going to put two stars and
then I'm going to like well it's not
like he's reviewing me I got to stick to
my gun well first of all I don't know if
well a he is reviewing you but B I don't
know there's no way he can see my review
before I see his there's no way the
system is based on him looking at what
he gave you yeah reviews are have to be
closed to both sides before before
they're both both got to be blind
airbn Airbnb you don't see the review
about you which you do see easily on
Airbnb once you submit the review about
the other person so I maybe you only see
aggregate I don't I decided Airbnb you
see the actual review oh I know for that
yeah um I stuck with my guns I put one
star and then it's like okay why and you
have to choose from the things and was
it like that's pretty harsh bro was it
like and it there were certain things in
there and one of them was wrong turn I
was like well Wrong Turn it was a big
Wrong Turn it's one of those when you go
the wrong way on the freeway and then
you're like well this is a twar wrong
turn like do you took two stars off of
the wrong turn how do we get from five
to one that's what I'm trying to figure
out emotionally
okay honestly so I clicked Wrong Turn
and then it was like okay anything else
anything and I didn't see anything else
but then it said other and I'm like yeah
well this the cigarette smell is
something people should know about so I
put other and then it brought up a whole
other thing and one of them was smell
yeah and so I clicked smell and I felt
bad about that were there smell options
there wasn't smell options it was just
smell and then I wrote because it could
be a good smell I wrote
cigarette smell cigarette smoke that's
what I wrote in the writing all right
and I I did not put a tip I usually tip
even if it's 3 days later and I'm
opening the app a month later I'm like
oh yeah I forgot to tip and then I'll
tip I'll I do always tip you really let
this guy have it and I it's your fault
and then I I submitted it and I felt
good about it and
now oh man this this road goes both
ways so I'm going to show you how to do
this do you think I was wrong first of
all do you think I was too harsh I mean
it was it was three strikes you're out
that would have been well maybe I was a
little hard I don't know one star feels
pretty pretty pretty hard pretty harsh
you know he'll I think he'll be okay
he'll probably be okay he also you're
not going to derail his career because
of this the thing is is that here's what
here's what I he had a billboard on top
of his car it was a LED screen turned
sideways like he was a piece of delivery
guy but the
LED billboard on his car was promoting
Uber oh and I'm like oh I got me a
professional Uber I got like wo this guy
has really got it going on yeah so he'll
be fine so my expectations were higher
but here's the other
thing related I have to
assume I pretty much have only ever
given five stars right even if it's like
I mean I kind of do the same thing with
with uh you know servers and restaurants
it's like unless unless you do something
like I'm like 20% is my is my Baseline
right and then if you do if if like you
said you were a fan I definitely go up
significantly if you did a great job
I'll go up significantly but like it's
only you have to have done something
rude that was your fault as a server you
offended me or something which I don't
know if this ever happened right when it
comes to the Uber thing I have given
some marks off if it's like the if the
cigarette smell was overwhelming
you know what I'm saying yeah but I
don't think I went to one star I was
just like all right I'm going to give a
little feedback here you kind of think
about that but you also got the wrong
turn so it was the double whammy but I
think people probably are like most of
the time it's five stars but then if I'm
upset at one star so it probably goes
for drivers there's probably a lot of
fives and ones so maybe it's fine but
let's look at our own okay okay and I
and correct me if I'm wrong if if if
y'all know about
this I think that if you cancel a ride
then they can give you a rating and and
that they'll give you a bad rating and
and I gotta say there's been multiple
times where there's been a cancelled
ride because of where I live and how
it'll be like this dude's not moving I
don't know if it's
service so you're getting nervous too
yeah yeah yeah yeah well I've already
looked at mine oh so you're explaining
okay so open up your Uber
app and they do they use this as a way
to decide if they're going to take your
request probably I don't know call in if
you're an Uber driver tell us how you
feel about what link did and also answer
any of the questions that we number is
1888 earpod one so go to the lower right
hand corner click on account account
okay uh now go to settings the bottom
part of the screen there settings
they've hidden it under settings okay
then click on
privacy privacy
really uh and then it's says your data
and privacy at Uber and then there is
this little icon and it says would you
like to see a summary of how you use
Uber and then click on C
summary I don't want to look at mine yet
okay explore your data how to use this
tool commitment to privac trust is
important so then scroll down
to
ratings well first of all thank you for
being with us for how many days have you
been with
Uber three
3,729 H
3,728 oh I signed up the day before you
everything everything we do in life is
like it's kind of on Pace one one day of
each other I've taken 179 trips I've
taken 224 which I don't think is a lot
of trips how many trips have y'all taken
if y'all are in this 509 9 mine is uh
around 800 uh
1990 something okay about the same as me
okay Jamie taking a lot more yeah a lot
of people take lift more okay I'm not I
use lift or it depends on if there's a
deal I scroll back in for I got KCK out
a lift and I don't know why oh no I'm
not I want to look at your data first so
show me what you got so if you're
following along you're going to scroll
down to ratings and then you're going to
click on view my ratings and and this
takes a while the first time it took to
generate this it like thought a lot now
I can just go back and see it okay well
I'm going to go ahead and click mine
just so it's going um cuz it's going to
ask you another question and ask you if
you're sure or something and then it
starts okay all right so
my aggregate
rating is
4.73 that's good that's which if I saw
4.73 on a driver I'd be like okay but i'
like to see 4.95 I like to see 4.9 four
it's only out of five right I'm just
saying I just I don't know how I think
that might be a little bit low so no 16
we're going to compare all we got all
four of us here so uh 165 five stars 13
four stars now those are I'm most
curious about those 13 four stars like
what what did I do what do you do as a
rider I don't do anything I don't I'm so
quiet maybe that's what it is maybe I
don't talk maybe I don't answer the
questions I think you're making I do
answer some I think you're making them
wait you have to walk down that long
driveway yeah I think you're late six
three
stars six two
star and two one star two all the one
star is just you they were about to be
at your place and you you I've done that
you cut them off yeah I I you sent them
packing well there's been a couple of
times from my home where I've had to
call an Uber and a lift at the same time
I'm like whoever gets here first gets
the ride because uh it can be so crazy
at certain times and now once I get the
other ride I cancel the other one and I
shouldn't do that but Stevie told me
this and it's true things have changed
man five years ago it would be like
finding your Uber your Uber is five
minutes away and five minutes later they
would be at your house now it says we're
looking for your driver it waits and
then it says nine minutes and a lot of
people in my neighborhood a lot of
drivers in my neighborhood who live in
my neighborhood they just got here's my
theory Maybe I'm Wrong they're parked at
their house they have their app on oh
they're on the toilet they're watching
the game they're doing whatever they
want to do and then they see oh somebody
needs a
ride okay yes and then then they then
they do something else like eat a
sandwich I don't know what happens but
they don't get in my house in 9 minutes
try to find matching socks and I'm just
saying it's changed a little bit so my
approach to the game has changed but
anyway so I'm I'm at a
4.73 that's still pretty good dude dude
that's a so you do a grab bag approach
and you'll so you'll you'll make them
race to your door an Uber and a lift I
may have done that three times in my
life I'm just saying that
it's under certain circumstances I've
had to do it please note ratings are
optional not everyone will give you a
rating writer ratings
4.76 oh dang link I'm six 10 six three
100s higher
your 3100 300 fire yeah that's what it
is 137 five star four four star four
three star zero two stars and six one
who okay this is the crazy thing why do
I have so many four stars I don't have
you you got six one Stars how did this
happen I'm heavy on the onear six one
star and then four four and four three
I've got quite a spread six two stars
you got zero two
stars What's Happening Here I I will say
that when I called The Uber from here
when you left me you remember that when
you forgot I existed and how much you
cared about me and I had to find my way
home so I called an Uber well I found
the Uber and then it was like I opened
my screen to see how far the Uber was
away and it at first it was like you
know 7 minutes away and then when it was
4 minutes I opened up the thing and I
was like oh 4 minutes and my thumb
clicked something and the next thing I
knew they were I had no ride and I think
I clicked
cancel and I think I've done that a lot
I think I've done that at least six
times apparently like just being old man
pushing like instinctively pushing a the
biggest
button for no reason so I've canceled on
accident but I feel good about this wow
I can I can now I can really move
forward wreaking some Havoc
4.76 Jenna you got to go next because
Jamie you've got the the biggest data
pool yeah
uh my score is
4.86 dang she's the winner I am a
delight but I will say I I have four one
Stars whoa four one Stars two two stars
one three star three four stars and 188
five star that's nice dang okay okay you
know the thing I'm realizing Lincoln has
my Uber account
oh you know oh this is Lincoln this
isn't even me why does he have his own
Uber account I don't know because I
don't know we just
never I just said if you ever need an
Uber when you're at college you know use
use the Uber but he should have his own
he proba has his own now because you
would see it happening a lot you would
see you would see the rides I'll get
emails and it and I I see his rides and
stuff and then I get then I tip his
driver because it's my account
[Laughter]
yeah you got he's making me T he's got
it made doesn't he and he's getting me
these one star reviews or he's probably
the four and three star I will say I
book rides for you all via my account
from time to time yeah I can't I I
probably should I can't blame the one
stars on you I'm pretty sure that's
that's that's on me at some point I
don't know it might be me drunk Jenna is
a delight oh damn but maybe a mess oh
gosh you made a mess I've never made a
I've never never in a in in Uber but
I've certainly been with my friends and
called Uber's places and like been in
the Uber with them and been like oh my
God please please please I'm going get a
B score get us out of here cuz that I
mean definitely been there yeah when you
started factor in like vomiting in
somebody's car and that can only the
worst that can be is a one star I feel a
little bad about giving my boy a one
star taking me home just for a wrong
turn and some cigarette smell I mean he
didn't vomit on me yeah yeah
yeah I you can look through your past
rides and I basically have given
everybody five stars but then like every
like 10th ride it says canceled because
it's like i' and yeah I shot myself in
the foot here okay Jamie okay so my I do
have a way bigger pool here but my
overall is
4.89 that's nice he's the winner but I
have so I have like five stars 417 rides
I have 10 four stars six three stars
three three two stars and four one stars
and I'm dang you got only four one stars
with that big of a pool yeah but I'm
still like in I have this story from
back like when Uber barely started and I
had an Uber driver ask me why is your
Uber rating so low and I was like what
do you mean sir I was like I am
delightful like you knew from the
beginning and no he was just like yeah
you have like a three point something so
I have definitely brought this up but I
want I was like trying to you like ask
you're like Hawking the good reviews
you're like and give me five stars when
you're getting out of the car you're
trying you were trying to like boost
your score no I was just like when that
happened I was like what do you mean
he's like yeah you seem cool to me and I
was like I feel like that is
accurate so what did you change because
you're like you're getting out of the
car and you're like let's just recap the
fun we had together you know I feel like
we had some five-star fun it might be
the questionnaire that I have printed
out in my purse but right that'll do it
every time give him a little candy I
agree though on the I'm here I'm like
why did I only get the three stars of
the ones why am I just at a mid what did
I do to be mid not even the four the
three stars are the ones that I'm like I
don't understand I mean being quiet is
not something to get dinged for um yeah
I'm trying to think of the things that
I've done I mean I've got i' got the low
score here I feel like I got make a
change being
tur could be could like if you're not
friendly in your conversation I guess a
driver
could ding you for that I'm just trying
to think like maybe you
smell not you I mean us collectively I
smell sometimes one could smell you
usually not when I'm
out or if you're like I smell at home if
you're talking on your phone really
loudly like I don't do that but that I
think that's worthy of a that's just in
I definitely do not endear myself to the
driver no I don't do that if my wife is
present she we'll know the life story of
yeah whoever is driving and maybe they
would get a low score for that she would
get a low score if they didn't want to
talk usually not I don't think so I
think they seem to be participating
pretty strongly I think if you just give
them a little friendly hello and a
friendly goodbye and a thank you and
nothing in between I think that's a good
book end I think that's a good practice
now if the Uber starts asking me stuff
like I don't say sometimes I'll put no
conversation cuz they when you call the
Uber they ask for your preference I love
that I never get the preference I put
I'm going start putting the I'm going to
put the no conversation cuz that way
it's like hey this is just this is just
how we're riding today maybe that will
increase your rating on average because
there's no expectation set I mean I in
the absence of doing that I have been
sparked up with an Uber and what I meant
by that is sparking
conversation I realiz it sounded like I
was smoking the cigarette I sparked up
with some of them sparking conversation
like they would try to get me talking
and be like what do you do for a living
you know that's the time I boldface lied
to my Uber I was like you said corporate
video I said I'm yeah it's not a lie
it's true I work in corporate video you
do cuz Google is a corporation and well
so is
mythical that's true okay well I feel a
little bit bad here guys I don't know I
don't I mean those sound the 4.8 4.9
that could if I see a driver that has my
rating like a 4.73 I'm like this guy's
made some mistakes honestly that's what
I think you rarely see some a driver
less than
4.6 so now I kind of feel like I'm kind
of at the bottom of the barrel at this
point what do you do when you see that
you don't cancel because then that's
going to give you a one star it just
raises here on my back a little bit yeah
yeah you know I'm like okay I got to be
real clear here I'm G to blame this on
my neighborhood that's what I'm blame it
it on they get lost coming up to my
house the loose service I have to give
them directions to get back to the
highway yeah that's not their fault
there's things like that that happen but
when I think they're taking it out on me
when you're calling an
Uber why I mean can you choose between
different people I'm seeing if you can
see their rating on the app before you
like choose which one you want I don't
think you can I don't think you can I
mean that just wouldn't be I think the
rating is mostly
for like if I'm the Uber people I'm
clicking on a car to be like rating gets
blow certain amount they you can't drive
anymore you go on a pro probation or
something okay so yeah so it's a little
disconnected the
rating but so I got a little something
to work on we'll check you know what
we'll check again next year if I can
beat you okay I like how you you make
the um the Uber and the lift race to
your house I do that with napping I've
started doing this new type of napping
where like I'll drink a coffee and then
I'll be laying there and I'll see if I
can beat the coffee to nap time because
if the coffee kicks in I'll wake up so I
got to fall asleep before the coffee
makes me wake up and it's kind of like a
I've pictured as like a race in my head
it's like my napping metabolism being
attacked by the coffee I just drank it
sounds like coun such a relaxing thought
exercise to make one fall asleep I mean
there's a race going on in my head I'm
about to dream I've got to hurry up a
nap before I wake up I did have like 30
minutes or so and then when you do up it
helps you it helps you wake up from the
nap at like more invigorated if you take
a caffeine nap caffeine power nap but I
I like the race of it all it's it's the
thrill for me I think I got to stop the
racing technique though I I want to be
clear I've only done it a few times and
my understanding is that the driver
still gets paid a certain amount they
don't get paid for the drive but they
get paid for the cancellation if they
did any driving if you care about your
rating and you got to work on it but you
got some leeway um I want to share with
you something uh that we finally get to
share I think we should save it I really
want to hear my I want to see my vision
board we're going to see both I just
don't think we have time I'm not pushing
this for time I don't
have anything as the vision board come
on
um so I was watching something with this
by the way shouldn't take a lot of time
Jesse exactly it's watching something
with Jesse and
uh I don't I even know how I came off
Came Upon This we were watching YouTube
videos together while working out and um
there was something where there was
a this guy who's like the world record
holder for speed reading and I don't
know if you have seen these videos like
there's some videos that are like of
someone speed reading no no there's like
there's a Tik Tok video going around of
this guy who's like taking a book and
like flipping through it in front of
these judges or something and it's
obviously fake not read there's no
person that could do that but this is a
guy who is like definitive like Guinness
World Records recognized and like
they're saying like oh what is he doing
and it was just I wasn't thinking oh I'm
GNA watch this so I can learn how to
speedread I was like oh this is
interesting so I'm going to keep
watching it and then by the end of it
the way that the guy explained it I was
like okay well maybe I'll try this
so basically what he did is he said he
watch the world's best do something you
were like I can do that no because of
the way he talked about it okay he he
because I've always just thought well
this I've always thought hey it's
[__] I was like these people aren't
actually reading that's what I thought I
thought they were faking it right I
didn't think they were faking it but or
they're like not really getting the
information yeah and then what he said
was he was like well what I'm doing is I
figured out that typically when you read
something if you're normal like me and I
think I'm actually a below average speed
reader is my
theory you kind of read something and
it's almost like there's a voice in your
head that's saying the words out loud
more or less you're like reading it and
there's
like so it's kind of going at the the
speed of speech and he's like that slows
you down so much and what you'll find is
if you just take your finger and you
just kind of run it across the line and
you con Vin your brain to stop having to
insist that you say it inside your brain
and you just realize that you're just
taking in the information you'll get to
a place where you are taking in the
information
conceptually and if you stopped and
thought about it you would realize that
you actually did get the
information and so I was like well let
me try that and so this is the thing
that happens to
me I I think I'm such a slow reader
because I'm a very easily distracted
reader and I read a lot but what happens
is MH if I if I get down into my
bed and I start
reading I like make
it literally sometimes like a page and a
half and then I'm like falling asleep
that's good right and so I'm like I
can't I'm not getting anything done and
also sometimes I'll start reading and I
realize that it's like that when you
when you find yourself driving and
you're like I think I've just driven for
5 minutes and don't know I don't
remember any of that yeah you have to go
back you do the same thing with I do the
same thing with reading quite a
bit and so what I found is I'm trying
this new
technique not because I'm trying to get
through a bunch of things faster but
because I'm so slow because I'm so
distracted that I found that by doing
this technique and I'm not actually
doing my finger every time now I'm just
kind of looking at it it makes me focus
more on reading and that's the reason I
ended up getting more I'm less likely to
fall asleep while reading because trying
to do this technique and you're not
going to be tested on it except for now
okay because I you know I'm like I'm
going to get a book I'm like looking
around the uh our office for a book we
have a bunch of decorative books I was
like let me get one of those and then I
I realized I have I got a fun
book um we were given Dr Emily Morris's
smart sex which I how to boost your sex
IQ and own your pleasure so from like SE
Timber last year she came on the show
yep and um she sent us the book was that
year before last anyway I think this is
out now but we have an uncorrected proof
so there might you might can oh I'll
spot all of them all the Inc
Corrections so uh I just think you need
to speed read uh can I but can I set the
bar for you real quick and I want to see
how well you get it because it's not I'm
not going to be you're not going to
handang me the book and give me 4
seconds and I give it back to you I have
to look at all of the words I'm just not
going to read the words out loud in my
mind so I'm going to go faster than
normal than for me well it's just a page
and a half and it's in a box so like
it's actually less so I would like for
you to speedread the uh section
on uh penis
popping
okay okay I'm not going to look yet uh
it's on the right side do you want to
like do you want to read it normal and
time I've already read it okay I just
don't know I don't think this is going
to be
impressive well I'm I'm going to go fast
I'm going to go as fast as I can a page
and a half so how much time do you need
I don't know I've never time myself you
got to go quick man I'm probably going
to give you 15 seconds can you not say
distracting things while I'm doing it
yeah I'm not going to yeah this is not
this is not for comedy do you make a low
humming noise just like a drone noise
just to let people know that they're the
podcast is still on like you want me to
make a gray noise yeah make it make make
white Bo you're a white boy make white
noise
but don't change
tones could it be more of a hiss like
a yeah just see it it's a little wet I
want to make it drier yeah make it drer
noise and here we
go
all right that's 15 seconds you're done
turn no no I'm I'm reading the whole
thing well you
need I could have read the whole thing
just normal I think no I couldn't have I
think that's over twice as fast now
you're really hurting me because you're
talking just get what you got from the
first page okay all
right so I was doing great until the
second half when you started
interrupting me and talking okay but I
want you to understand I just read five
paragraphs and I don't know how long
that was but that was way faster than I
typically would read and I was just
looking at the words and then letting
them register in my brain I can safely
say that I would have read it at 25%
speed of what you did okay I am a slow
reader except when it's horny stuff I
guess I don't know what I'd be at so can
I give you a summary or you GNA ask me
questions like give me give me a summary
of penis popping okay well
basically the idea behind behind this is
that uh sex is messy right so there are
lots of things that can happen during
sex like vagina farts is one of the
things that can happen during sex so
there's you know the expectation that
you're going to have every hair in place
and everything is going to be perfect
when you're having sex is an unrealistic
expectation and one the word the word
vagina farts is in here and one of the
things not queef and one of the things
that can happen is penis popping which
is when the penis slips out of the hole
that it's in
uh the vagina in this case I think in
this particular example during sex now
at this point I'm simultaneously
relieved and disappointed because when I
first picked this I was like oh my gosh
this is going to be about my my worst
night like when it's like cuz there's
different chambers in a wiener you don't
want to break your penis and then if one
of those if one of those pops like a
balloon that's disturbing can I go on
and tell you the rest of it but you're
are correct in saying that that is not
what penis popping is so right off the
bat you haven't you're not you're not
making this up cuz what my first test
was is he just GNA make up what he
thinks penis popping is when you said
penis popping I thought you were talking
about when it breaks yeah so it makes a
popping noise you you circumvented the
misdirect continue and uh
basically this is all a function of the
the angle of Entry right it's it's
something that happens It's a
combination of the angle of entry and
something else I can't remember the
position I think and so you can
experiment with if this is something
that happens on a regular basis you can
experiment with cowgirl or reverse
cowgirl that can change the the
positions and then some people actually
just want to move to something simpler
like
missionary uh which could be a good so
basically you need to experiment you
don't need to feel ashamed these are
things that happen but you need to find
you know you need to find your own Mojo
your own a good reason to
what call your mom what yeah I haven't
called my mom in a while like I'm I'm
waiting for my penis to pop
out I don't understand the kind of the
question potential penis slippage is
also a good reason to not call your
mom uh penis slippage is a good is also
a good reason to I don't know I missed
that slow things down slow things down
slow things down right let me go
backwards here um that was in the second
half that's why you were talking I was
listening to you reading at the same
time what type of penises will become
more comic than tragic if you
Embrace awkward
moments popped
penises no disobedient penises
okay okay and um so you're not really
getting good with the details was that
in the last paragraph on that page that
was in the that was in the intro
paragraph yeah I mean you you do you end
up missing some stuff and also I mean I
just don't remember everything if it
happens to you who cares that's a
question nobody exactly you got that
right your mom you you can make light of
it you can laugh together or um you can
do what try a new position or just
what go with the flow add some music
Lube lube and get that penis back in
there yeah that was it that was get that
penis back in there that was a you got
that
part keep in the keep in mind that a
slow insertion grind
grind swivel or what motion is likely to
cause more popping than moving up and
down
uh lateral thrusting
back and forth motion I don't I don't
even know who's who's right anymore okay
you've done it okay but so let me tell
you what I did uh I applied this I was
over the holidays I was reading a book
um I think it's called like the tiger or
something and it's a u i don't know I
was told by somebody on Tik Tok I I'm on
like book talk you know and like
listening to people talk about things
and somebody was talking about this
being like a page Turner and I was like
okay and I got into it and it was uh a
book
about these dudes in the like eastern
most part of Russia which is like a
really desolate jungle region where
there's like the Siberian tiger the as
Asiatic tiger okay and they're like
basically tracking a tiger that had
killed some people and it's based on a
true story and but it's a
historical it's a retelling of the story
with some imagined I don't know what you
call that genre where you're telling a
story that actually happened but it's a
little fictionalized it's not historical
fiction because it's more it's a
documentary of it but embellished tale
of reality this dude would go into
deep
deep like history and information about
the region and about all this stuff and
I was kind of like this is hard man this
is hard to get through but I just feel
like I'm so bad and I and I was started
the book in end of 2023 and it was like
coming into 2024 I was like I want to
finish this damn book I don't want to
just stop another book yeah and this
technique came along oh penis popping
and uh yeah penis popped my way right
through that book and then called my mom
and told her i' had done it uh no
actually I sped read again it's not
crazy I don't know if somebody would be
like that dude's reading the hell out of
that book I think they would just be
like that dude's reading normally
whereas before it would be like that
dude's reading a page and a half and
falling
asleep and you're like skipping areas
where you don't feel like you need all
the details I did I know I did did not
do that well you're you're speed
skipping you're skimming but I was like
I you like it makes you like engage with
it and then you like have to and then
sometimes you hit to you hit a place and
you're like this is something that I
have to slow down and take in every
single word and say it out loud in my
head and maybe go back but then the slow
grind they call it and then and I got
through the book like I it had taken me
three weeks on and off to get like 40%
of the way through the book
and then it took me a week to
finish and I was like this could be this
could be Revolution and you enjoyed the
book more yeah and I and I like remember
a lot about the way that the book that
that that second 60% this is a you
didn't do any more research besides that
you one video it was just instead of
reading it out loud to myself in my mind
I just was like I'm going to make my
eyes move across the words faster than I
think my brain can keep up with and then
you start thinking oh I actually just
got all that it's in
there
yeah
um and I just speed read that doggy
style is the position that is most
likely to cause a penile fracture which
is what you thought penis popping was
yeah that's this just the next page so I
mean I I recommend it I mean you don't
just go on my word watch a video about
it is that your recommendation it's not
yeah let's make it my recommendation cuz
I'll save my other recommendation for
next time but um cfor time it's not
[__] it's it's not [__] like it
actually does work I never thought it
was well some of the videos are [__]
somebody picking up a book and going and
just being done with it that's [__]
man and there's people who do that okay
um we have as much time as we
need to for me to experience my vision
board that Jenna has worked on I don't
know how hard she's worked on it maybe
I'll be able to tell when I look look at
it maybe you're going to give it a scale
of one to five stars yeah yeah give me
an Uber rating okay all right here we go
I'm going to look at it first oh wow
holy moly look at this it got pills on
it yeah it does have
pills oh oh my gosh Jenna I didn't see I
didn't see the the letters I thought you
gave him some
pills look at this here's your vision
for 2024 take these pills I'm Jenna I am
going to take this to therapy and take
full credit for it
okay hey therapist I've been doing some
work on my own and I just wanted to
share it with you this is this is this
might be framable look at this wow it's
got It's got a three-dimensional vibe to
it there's leaves so what does this say
gr ground ground ground yeah and here's
a snowboarder uhhuh and here's the Moon
Sun uhhuh here's a map mhm with some
islands some angular shapes AV on guard
bicycles Bic oh is this a bicycle mhm
well look at that mountain biking
snowboarding what does ground mean like
staying grounded staying grounded okay
yeah yeah
yeah um there's a there's a heart here
replenish stay hydrated maybe yep
napping with dogs there's literally a
man napping with or maybe
he he could be dead no he's napping with
dogs there's multiple dogs yeah the dogs
will stick around after you die though
oh my God you have a man uhhuh napping
with a dog and then you have a scuba
diver some Adventure here got an
underwater thing connect connecting with
nature connecting with my son perhaps
yeah when I go scuba I like I like
connection it's a good filter I like
apply to things like is this enhancing
my connection with my fellow
man here is an actual is that poison ivy
no and then okay male sorted okay yeah
cuz my number one thing was uh sexual
activity yeah yeah what else if I missed
here um I put I put a hummingbird in
there with and on all the leaves that uh
Christy oh there's a hummingbird is that
a fortune cookie the house
plants it's kind of like a little
fortune cookie down there yeah what does
that say you never talked about music so
I added a little thing about music
you're right yeah you know what Christy
went out and I went on a date after that
conversation about like ranking our
favorite stuff from the last episode and
we had a great conversation about that
yeah a good date conversation and then I
realized I was like you know I didn't
put anything about music on there that's
okay I thought of that cuz I was like
listening to music and then playing
music two different things both on my
list without music and love life is a
journey through a desert oh wow harsh
yeah that I hope this didn't take as
long as it looks like it took cuz how
long think it took um it looks like a
2hour affair
here yeah that's about right yeah but
but do you had fun doing it right I did
have fun it was a fun like Sunday the
only thing I did on company time was use
the printer and I don't have a printer
at home this this is this is this is me
this is this is this is the
this is the experiential pleasure me
yeah look at that that is beautiful I'm
not going to ask you to make me one okay
thank you I'm going to ask you not to
make it more I've I've got the big I've
different I've got the pen and ink thing
you know yeah right I've got it I don't
you know I don't you don't need to spend
any more company time this on doing a
vision board for me and I'm not going to
burn this okay unless my therapist tells
me that I should you about it before
maybe the end of the year you burn it mm
you take a picture of it first yeah it's
the end of year you've you've completed
your vision and then you can release it
into the fire yeah Phoenix come from
Back From the Ashes I don't know I I'll
be in an Uber when I'm burn burn it okay
yeah yeah yeah that'll help help the
rating what is what is my star what is
my star rating this this this is this is
this is too good I appreciate it and and
it's uh I'm going to stare at it
whenever I need the perspective of
pleasure thank you for that yeah I'll be
there maybe
maybe no it just cracked okay and it's
on fire oh no all the pills fell off the
vision the vision is is being
destroyed very few words easy to
speedread all right we've been through a
lot today um we're that much closer to
each other yeah listen hey leave us
leave us those voicemails that we asked
for you know dare us to respond with
with your assertion we want to hear from
you 1888 Ear Pod one and of course #
earbiscuits and leave us a review or
rating uh if you haven't it's helpful
especially if it's U you know good like
our Uber scores five stars hi R and Link
I just finished listening to the episode
where link talks about his New Zealand
trip and I just wanted to say as a mail
carrier I can verify that it is weird to
be driving on the other side of the car
but you'll get used to it if you keep
doing it love you
guys